Как добиться успеха в любом деле,
начиная с нуля? Я много размышлял над
этим принципом и над этим правилом и в
жизни очень часто его применял. Я
размышлял над тем, как, ну, и что нужно
делать для того, чтобы с нуля очень
быстро добиться успеха в любом деле. И
применял в различных ситуациях в жизни и
спрашивал других людей. И я каждый раз
убеждаюсь, насколько сильно это правило,
и насколько 100% железно оно работает. К
сожалению, большинство людей это не
принимает, не применяют и не знают об
этом правиле. Проблема всех людей в том,
что когда они начинают какое-то дело,
они начинают с того, чтобы хотят
получать много и сразу, отдавать
постепенно и помаленьку. Приведу вам
такой пример. Когда человек приходит на
работу, он сразу выставляет все свои
хотелки. Хочу за такую-то зарплату, хочу
вот это, хочу это, хочу это, хочу это.
Что дальше происходит? Это вызывает
определённое отторжение со стороны
работодателя. Потому что, когда человек
вываливает всё, что он хочет,
получается,
работодатель становится в позицию, в
ситуацию, когда он вынужден покупать
кота в мешке за непомерно большую цену.
И, соответственно,
на ваше обращение, на ваше резюме будет
меньше отклика. Или, например, когда вы
начинаете какой-то бизнес, вы сразу
выставляете вот такую цену или какие-то
особые требования. В результате у вас
мало покупателей. Для того, чтобы
добиться успеха в любом деле с нуля, вы
должны действовать конт интуитивно, на
180° наоборот. Вы должны отдавать много
и сразу, а получать помаленьку и
постепенно. Когда вы начинаете любое
дело с нуля, не имеет значения. Это
бизнес, общественная деятельность,
политическая деятельность, не имеет
абсолютно никакого значения. Запомните
это правило, ещё раз подчеркну, оно
очень контрнтуитивно.
отдавать много и сразу, а получать
постепенно и помаленьку. Это приводит
железнобетонно, железобетонно со
стопроцентной вероятностью к успеху. Как
это работает в жизни и вообще откуда я
взял это правило? Я в своей жизни
сталкивался много раз с такими
ситуациями. И так как я всю жизнь много
работаю с волонтёрами, я заметил такую
вещь.
На эту мысль меня натолкнул один случай
с волонтёром. Когда он пришёл выполнять
определённую работу, так как он волонтёр
на бесплатной основе, то он начал
предлагать делать не то, что не только
основную работу, но ещё много
дополнительной работы. Он готов и то
сделать, и это сделать, и это сделать.
Оказывается, он ещё разбирается в IT.
Оказывается, он разбирается в
программировании, оказывается, он умеет
настраивать Excel. Оказывается, он ещё
может вести вечеринку, быть там одной и
так далее. И таким образом я заметил
такую вещь, что я подспудно захотел
больше с ним работать. Я начал больше с
ним работать. Через какое-то время он
продолжал также отдавать всё много и
сразу. В какой-то момент я почувствовал
внутри, что этот человек, э, мне лучше
платить деньги этому человеку, иначе он
уйдёт, либо его запал пропадёт и так
далее. Я начал платить ему деньги.
Дальше в какой-то момент
это были небольшие деньги. Я понял, что
если мне не поднять цену до рыночной
цены, то он может уйти. А у меня мысль
была такая: "Блин, классный парень, а
надо платить ему рыночную цену, иначе он
уйдёт". Я поднял до рыночной цены. И так
как человек, парень этот продолжал
работать дальше и выкладываться по
полной программе и отдавать всё и сразу,
то в какой-то момент я начал его
поднимать, э, по карьерной лестнице, а,
соответственно, увеличивая а его
заработную плату. Таким образом, он
достиг очень высоких позиций за
достаточно короткое время. Буквально в
течение полгода он вырос до очень
хороших позиций у меня в компании. И я
для себя понял, вот когда посмотрел со
стороны, что же произошло, я понял, что
он делал. Он это делал неосознанно,
конечно, а из-за того, что он по натуре
такой человек, но он, оказывается,
действительно отдавал много и сразу, а
брал постепенно и помаленьку. Я
представил, вот если бы он пришёл ко мне
и занимался бы только тем делом, ради
которого он пришёл, то есть волонтёр
пришёл там, а, на какое-то одно дело и
занимался бы только этим, то он бы не
раскрыл бы свой талант, свои способности
мне, соответственно, я был не был бы
заинтересован в нём дальше. А так как он
отдавал много и сразу, то я увидел
несоответствие того, что он просит у
меня и то, что даёт. И это заставило
меня переживать и бояться, что этот
человек уйдёт, потому что слишком
большая ценность против, э, той цены,
которую он запрашивает. И таким образом,
а, он очень быстро поднялся у меня, э,
по карьерной лестнице в компании.